[Musique]
ce mardi 17 juillet s'est déroulée la
signature de la convention du pacte de
solidarité territoriale avec la commune
de saint-andré un dispositif initié par
cyrille melchior président du
département afin d'aider les communes de
l'île ce parc représente tout simplement
un partenariat très fort entre la
commune de saint-andré et le département
moi je crois qu'on ne peut pas
travailler les uns à côté des autres
je veux travailler les uns avec les
autres
il sera donne de la cohérence à l'action
publique et à saint-andré je sais que le
maire et son équipe ont beaucoup d'idées
il y a plein d'actions menées dans le
domaine social et dans le domaine de
l'aménagement
le département est auprès du maire et de
la d élite s'attendre et de la
population de s'attendre et moi le mieux
vivre chez sept communes de l'est
une signature qui a débuté par la pose
de la première pierre du chantier de
l'avenue de la république qui sera le
point de départ de l'opération
renouvellement urbain d'abord le premier
symbole c'est la solidarité entre le
conseil départemental et la ville le
deuxième c'est que ce contrat du va
servir à moderniser la ville de
saint-andré et améliorer la crête déduit
de la population tant qu'on peut dire
trois axes embellir la ville améliorer
la qualité de vie et rassembler le plus
possible de gens en allant au devant
date de ces personnes pour qu'elles
puissent participer à la vie de la
société
après saint pierre et si la hausse en
juin ternissent saint-andré la troisième
commune à avoir signé le pacte de
solidarité territoriale
[Musique]